one minute and five seconds of holy Sh
we hit the mother lode of logos reading
discount Home Depot product placement
also home Mart you can come up with a
better Home Depot Walmart ripoff name
than that this guy trying to sneak chips
into a sandwich thinks that Denzel won't
hear that when he bites down onto it
sabot got two guys that work at home
Mart might be friendly even close but
they are not letting each other finger
touch their food have Hollywood
screenwriters ever held real jobs Denzel
Washington is lonely as fuck movies
obsessed with clocks honestly not sure
what's worse here the heart-shaped
headphones are the fact that they say
love on them with little hearts in place
of the Oh as Denzel made a movie with
every blond precocious child star this
diners prices are all out of whack
coffee is a dollar fifty fifty percent
more than King McDonald's corned beef
hash is 250 a price that seems low for
anything containing meat but then two
eggs toast and home fries are $7 I mean
there's simply no standard whatsoever
for the pricing of the food in this
diner we bet know what you do for you
got it
like for a living I'm saying this
sharable discussion leads - bullsh open
questioning of a co-worker so that
bullsh mystery about a character
background can continue bullshitting me
to death
the old man's got to be the old man it's
got to be to fish got to be who you are
in his world right prostitute Chloe
grace Moretz steals the jodie foster
from taxi driver so he gets up early
works are regular job is kind to hookers
in fact co-workers I get it he's awesome
or at the 15-minute mark and the movie
start happening please the equalizer
takes the badass former government agent
helps the young girl with her singing
career thing from taken I think you can
be anything you want to be you know
provided you can impress the gatekeepers
of the industry you want to break into
all so she can't be the starting center
for the Boston Celtics or the Pope or a
horse change of wool he said to the
obviously institutionalized hooker yeah
you know everything so dark makes
everything's impossible again I know
she's a lost way too young kong girl but
what the hell is that supposed to mean
oh survivor guy who thinks he's a knight
in shining armor the only thing is he
lives in a world where nice don't exist
anymore nice that the 90 second book on
the list is Don Quixote allowing this
dialogue to be extra heavy-handed
somehow Elena's pimp knew that she'd be
walking out to this gas station tonight
and this is definitely not a routine
because we saw her catching a cab from
the diner the first time we saw this
girl
don't go here's my business card so
you'll know where to kill me later she's
at the ICU it's shammed someone beat her
up real good thanks extremely helpful
diner guy it's amazing how much news you
hear about prostitutes in your line of
work they beat up his hooker
acquaintance no one beats up his hooker
acquaintances carnival Meditation $9,000
fuckin throttle me
one month bad guy adds a clause to the
agreement after the handshake cliche
whorehouse of the Crystal Skull movie
steals the hero can figure out every
move bad guys are going to make in a
fight thing from Sherlock Holmes also
bad guys just let this guy sit here and
stare at them for a really long time
when I'm doing or saying anything 15
seconds
it then takes him 28 actual seconds in
movie time but in real life it was 68
movie stills yet another page from taxi
driver as he kills a bunch of dudes who
sell underage girls in the skin trade at
least they don't sell heroin flavored
bananas am i right James Bond on the
next the equalizer yep he went all the
way home before washing the blood off
his hands
that just happened these are for you I
made the way damn couldn't you pick an
easier container than the notoriously
tough Pringle scan to deliver this
message or just telling like a normal
person the special report crawl needs to
tell us that the price of gas is 358 per
gallon before continuing with the story
of the five men who were killed last
night
all right you seen Robbie I was we
taking that security guard test after
work calling and quit to someone who
bothers to put a note about his weight
loss at a Pringles can seem to be the
type that quits closed closed what the
ever-loving first off Robert open the
door freely second off it's broad
daylight outside and third the hours
posted clearly state that you're closed
at 9:00 p.m.
not when Wheel of Fortune is on this
Russian villain is only a few tailgating
SUVs shy of a proper evil motorcade
Molina cebause all these guys this
exposition dialogue while driving is so
Grand Theft Auto unconvinced it's on
purpose do me a favor write whatever you
do don't call him Little John okay well
you never told me his nickname in the
first place so that's kind of weird and
why would you randomly bring this up and
subliminally plant a seed in his head
hey you ever meet this guy don't call
him penis face II hate such the
additional 10% you steal we ignore we
anticipated as your people are such
clichés that's racist also a movie with
nearly every single action movie cliche
in it including this very character is
distasteful of cliches well someone saw
a red dragon
besides Brett Ratner and me I mean also
this guy's nipples are
dribbly hard right now that's the lady
down the street I had to fire a thing
could happen to you with your whole
fucking family Oh first off this phone
got some remarkable audio which leads to
the second point these assholes are
actually shaking down businesses with
witnesses around and didn't notice
someone taking cellphone video can hurt
more than the beat and those corrupt
cops were never corrupt again
Ralphie's mom stupidly goes to the
window to pull out a wad of cash Brenda
with the reason then to show us her
customers and any criminal looking
inside she got it back yep they just
take you back immediately at jobs you
quit with no notice from that's totally
how life works bad guy pretends to be
really sweet only to kill someone cliche
professional killer does this in full
view of the front door and numerous open
windows but oh look he passed the
security guard exam which he actually
missed completely due to quitting his
job in sweeping up the Mexican
restaurant that day instead but I'm sure
they just give out makeup tests for that
thing like candy as opposed to making
truant applicants wait another six
months or whatever it is till the next
mass testing date this fuss and walks in
the front door several minutes off the
Slaven arrived it never comes out wait
you were looking earlier at Street
security footage showing him in the girl
coming out right congratu suddenly
everywhere Robert goes there are crimes
being committed right in front of him
also who robs a whole Mart in broad
daylight anyway and I was like he's
basically addicted to being a violent
vigilante and the names of people who
are essentially strangers every bad guy
in this movie has some sort of skull on
their person I know you want to get that
guy for stealing from the store but did
you need to steal a hammer from the
store
movie that is all about Denzel kicking
ass skips over prime opportunity to show
us Denzel kicking ass he waited until he
was back at work with coworkers in the
fucking aisle this thing goes in before
wiping off the blood he's on camera
right now also Robert stalks a used
hammer for resale also that was the most
senseless weapon and method of weapon
retrieval he could possibly have chosen
to beat up or kill the mugger he's
killed dozens already with his fists and
whatever he finds in the room but for
this one asshole he decides to steal on
camera from the place where he works I
need to take him clean live place about
coming there's no witnesses Teddy wants
to know who this guy works for but he's
already heard about Robert visiting the
beat up hooker in the hospital how can
be so good an investigation but not
consider the Travis Bickel angle oh
hello there vo I nearly missed you but
you're too sunny movies like robots and
a Marvel flick you know like Denali
Jerell Boston Herald truck randomly
makes an appearance in front of the
diner to block these guys views a very
nice instructions I'm gonna kill you yes
Ted
usually this place has quite a few
people in it but tonight of all nights a
perfect scenario by which only the bad
guy and the good guy occupy space in the
whole diner dream ah got a side front
follow but see I got free Teddy knows
that Robert has a considerable set of
skills yet allows everyone to split up
thereby allowing Robert to easily take
on one guy if it comes to that hero
villain Kicks down the door where you
think the hero villain is but the hero
villain is somewhere else cliche Susan I
just need to know who this man is
Oh your dumb ass cell phone did not take
a picture that was this good
to the point of being a perfect portrait
of Teddy your friend here is who Pushkin
sends when he's got a problem no matter
what the situation teddy has his picture
taken like he's going to be on a
baseball card he won't stop until he
kills you and anyone you care about
well at least after he gets to know you
first in come Braun came for permission
seriously the guy with no qualms about
killing numerous people in this movie
needs permission to kill the bad guy
also damn I never thought I'd say this
in my lifetime but this movie really
wastes Bill Pullman amazing how every
person in this movie has the same damn
Sony phone this guy who is on high alert
decides to go straight to the car
instead of checking for people who might
kill him inside the garage why don't you
get out of here go yes so you can
motherfucker come on the stewed would
already be talking by now who is he
actually protecting at this point he's a
dead man as far as his employers are
concerned anyway so he's handcuffed to
something and Denzel has a remote
control but does the car not have
interior buttons to roll down the
windows or open the fucking door
Denzel is gone since when do remote
dongles override all other controls for
a car Bonnie's able to trick his way
into the crime syndicate of the Russian
who obsessively wants to kill him
because a guy like that would never pass
out pictures of his obsession kill
target to the people who work for him
can I see it hugs ensue moans oh good
god man how in the world does this plan
work he'll get too close to me I'll take
his gun and nobody in the whole place
will have itchy trigger fingers and blow
me away when I do that the right thing
actually that is one of the few Spike
Lee movies you're not in but thanks for
playing
Shih Tzu sir so you found this then
closed it all up again just so you could
dramatically reveal it to this guy my
men will find you thanks dude
we probably established that a long time
ago probably before this dinner even but
good to get a reminder once in a while
shouldn't you just let it go to
voicemail
don't you by ignoring the call after
three rings communicate to the other
party that you actively
toward their call he's not coming back I
guess Robert just destroyed that guy in
the bathroom and luckily no one was
around to see it even a bathroom
attendant which they have in classy
places like this
I guess no one stumbles on this dude's
body either not while Roberts here
anyway I have no feelings about you one
way or the other except for being
obsessed about tracking you down and
killing you which is totally not a
feeling man
so this good man opened his home to this
point movie pauses the action two
minutes for Robert to tell a story about
Teddy's secret all of our twisted days
this is the second time this movie will
put Bobby at kill distance from the main
bad guy without letting him actually
kill him because this movie needs it's
two-hour 12-minute length damn it for
story Scarlett's about me is the exact
same as Crystal's about me in fact they
have the same age and same height
despite the fact that the stuff Robert
clicks on shows different ages and
different heights when picking illegal
Russian escort services I expect their
website to be well maintained check your
personal email make sure you sitting
down when you do because I just emailed
you all the gigabytes as an attachment
of course walking away from the fireball
had to be in this movie at some point
this is just like man on fire only with
a more grown-up Dakota Fanning I mean
Chloe grace Moretz there is no way he
could have time these gas based
explosions to perfectly match his slow
and steady escape walk funny how they
got pictures of Robert doing best buddy
things with Rafi especially since we
didn't see that during the bad guys take
photos of Robert see also he's going to
infer just from this photo that these
two are close enough to constitute
leverage which would be bad enough on
its own at this photo weren't also
several days old meaning this guy is
just now having this epiphany after
having these pictures for days your life
for that go ahead and kill them I don't
even know who they are also the
supposedly smart teddy commits a
cardinal bad guys sin and doesn't bring
an insurance hostage with him to his
location
just in case Robert decided to save the
home Mart employees mr. McCall Robbie
they came into the store then they
commit yet another horrible cardinal sin
by allowing Ralphie to disclose their
location amateurs man they knew you
worked here ages ago goddammit and only
just now thought of the kidnap the
co-workers plan
my men haven't we Denzel answered call
waiting how do you end that call and
interrupt him with beeps they can track
his location by cell phone but still
needed this elaborate desperate ruse to
find and kill it
she's fury can you just kill one of them
and then go investigate the music on the
PA also it's just music right who cares
you basically drop everything just to go
investigate music do you how stupid that
sounds coming out of my mouth now try
watching it we just king saw an exterior
shot that had no Denzel in it I don't
care how well Robert speaks Russian his
accent should have tipped that off
immediately very clever mr. McCall not
really any trained professional badass
would have been able to pull this off
the way you blender the thing I decided
to come see you for the third time this
movie yeah I'll be waiting for you
instead of killing you easily like I
could have done twice in this movie
already find the hostages then the
supposedly smart bad guy doesn't even
set up henchmen around the exits to make
sure no one got out or can't get out
movie turns into Home Depot alone thank
goodness the bad guys decided to explore
the Isles in such a way that leaves
Bobby time to set booby traps
you know Robert would make a pretty good
horror movie villain if we watch this
from the perspective of the bad guys
Denzel would be like Jason or Michael
Myers huh you can butane torch a
doorknob in a darkened Home Depot
without anyone hearing it or seeing the
light from the flame ooh new Home Depot
alone to Boston aisle two at new work
why hasn't Robert taken one of the bad
guys guns yet this guy really loves
killing people with tools during all the
commotion around the bathroom fixtures
and none of the remaining bad guys show
up to help out ah
after going the whole movie being
untouchable Bobby suddenly starts
meeting guys that can hit him and hang
with him near the film's conclusion I'm
sure it's just a coincidence
rafi decides not to bother with any
indication that he's around when
sneaking up on Robert who he just found
out as a deadly killer and just iced a
guy with a mirror shard ah these guys
had rifles with night vision scopes on
them that's the best they could do
trophy should not leave anybody behind
okay first of all Ralphy is a dumbass
second of all recently passed the
security guard exam Ralphie is better
equipped to find Bobby in this place
than actual trained soldiers okay so the
breakers were off and there wasn't any
power and how did robert set up this
microwave to suddenly start cooking
complete with a countdown and everything
once the power came back on even if he
set this up before the breakers were
turned off the microwave wouldn't
suddenly start up like this because
microwaves aren't that smart also Bobby
knew that these people terrible at their
job would be smart enough to follow his
blood trail into the break room at just
the right time
this work you knew they'd find a way to
make it rain during the sequence even
though it's inside that's right folks
it's Denzel he's got his own theme song
and man does he look cool in slow-mo
while the sprinkler system rains down in
the hallmark movie almost goes full Sin
City here at the end I think ironic
raindrops are actually more poignant
than actual tears don't you what do gain
from my dad I don't get my Robert
doesn't just kill this guy already of
course we know he's got something fucked
up ready to go I mean this is sort of
left up to chance
Robert has to hope this works but I
guess he just knew it would what happens
if the guy is a least bit wary of tricks
like this or is in any way smart all
this for a hooker he once discussed old
man in the sea with a diner Danice girl
disappeared for 90 minutes of the movie
and she's the whole reason this got
started good job - like a real job
you're allowed you'll be happy to know
that the girl too young to ever have
started hooking has in the absence of
Russian overlords gotten some kind of
menial job she sure to hate in three
weeks
and just in case you weren't convinced
this movie that's pieced together from
almost all movies here's mobis version
of new dawn fades which is pretty much
identified with the movie heat taking us
to the credits and the moral of the
story is if your wife is dead and you
use your military training to avenge a
beaten up hooker your next move is
Craigslist
final shot really really wants you to
credit it for resembling a famous
painting don't call them Little John
okay
then change a wall
let me get this straight I still you
dope and then you walk in here and you
bring me more man you got one part of
that wrong this is not math oh I'm
Batman I don't know who you are I don't
know what you want if you are looking
for a ransom I can tell you I don't have
money but what I do have are a very
particular set of skills skills I've
acquired over a very long career skills
that make me a nightmare for people like
you but uh sucking me you don't want to
hear that I can cigarettes put out of me
when I was a little kid the mother could
stab me you don't want to hear that
Scylla
where were the other drugs going I never
knew I don't know I swear - swear to me